ووصل مخاوف من اعمال عنف جديده اذا ما تم
اعتقال ترامب يخطط انصار الرئيس السابق
للاحتجاج لكن على طريقتهم الخاصه وهو ما
يعيد للاذهان الهجوم على مبنى الكابيتول
في السادس من يناير 2021 اثرى خساره
الانتخابات الرئاسه امام جو بايدن حيث
اقتحم حينها انصار ترامب مبنى الكونجرس
لكن هذه المره يبدو ان التفكير انصار
ترامب سيكون مختلفا بينما يواجه اتهامات
تتعلق بمدفوعات سريه قدمها لممثله لشراء
صمتها ابانا انتخابات 2016
فبحسب صحيفه فان انصار ترامب يخططون
الاستنزاف المصارف حيث يندفع عدد كبير من
المذيعين لسحب اموالهم من البنوك في وقت
واحد وهو ما قد يؤدي الى ازمه مصرفيه ضخمه
في وقت تعاني فيه البلاد من تبعات ازمه
انهيار مصرف سيليكون ذلك قبل ايام